i think i'd be better off back in prison
john is 29 he can't get through a single
day
without alcohol he's also in poor health
and relies on prescription painkillers
so these are 600 milligrams
they're the strongest ones you can get
you've got 50 of them
it's five o'clock now and by the end of
tonight you will have had all of these
oh most of them yeah does that worry you
that you're taking that many more it
gets rid of me pain
john is in an age group of men in the
north of england
who are statistically speaking living
shorter
lives than those in the south and i'm
trying to find out why
with the help of researchers at
manchester university
we've built up the most comprehensive
picture of
a health divide that exists between the
north and the south of england
the numbers we thought were
staggering for the first time we can see
what the biggest killers of men are and
ask
why they're so much higher in the north
if something's
killing more men and then anything else
is killing young men
you direct the money towards that to try
and put a stop to it or try and limit it
but they just don't seem to be doing
that there's a northern macho
attitude and to have to admit to having
a problem
is is very difficult so the problems get
worse before they get any better
in some places i found a kind of
seething bitterness
towards the south northern men could
make it big down south
give them the opportunities send them up
here and see how they like it
that's the difference i was born and
brought up in the north
and i want to know what's really going
on why is the north
so far behind the south in so many
different ways
england's a tiny country in fact it's
only 346
miles long yet levels of inequality here
are staggering it's a nation of haves
and have-nots
so how is it that from where we've just
taken off to a few miles south of here
people's life chances and the life
chances of men
in particular can be so very different
[Music]
in this line 18 special report we look
at what makes this
a deadly divide and ask whether
successive governments
have turned their backs on the north
five decades of death records tell a
tale of two englands
the north and the south researchers say
that since 1965
around 1.2 million more people have died
before the age of 75
in the north of england than in the
south by the mid 1990s
there was very little difference between
early deaths in the north and south
but by 2016 a gap had opened up
an average of 1177
more men aged between 25 and 44
died in the north than in the south each
year
to find out why this gap is wider you
have to go back to one
decade in particular
[Music]
the ladies not a turtle
the 1980s a decade of social and
economic change
huge swathes of industry in the north
collapsed
and unemployment soared but the south
fared better london grew as a financial
center
and a new service economy attracted
investment
drove up house prices and brought
increased wealth
i've come to meet professor evan conto
pantellas whose research revealed a
spike in northern deaths
from 1990 onwards there has been a very
big increase
which led to a 15
increase in mortality basically which is
a big number
so something's happening from the 1990s
to now which is killing
this age group more than their
counterparts in the south
and particularly men particularly the
[Music]
men
council budgets in blackpool have been
slashed by nearly 140
million pounds in the last seven years
it has the highest
drug related death rate in england and
wales
and alcohol's a huge problem too and do
you think every day
every day without fail without fail i
first met
john a few months ago he was on a
mission to get to his gp's before it
closed can you imagine
a day where you don't drink
where it where it or you don't drink a
lot i don't know what i thought drink me
won't be able to get out the old slots
but if you got help on a programme
like a detox program would you do that
no
well he was a good kid when he was young
you know they were saying that he was
well above average intelligence and
uh and then when he got to the edge of
about 11
his nada was checking marijuana for
paying i think
probably after eight years or something
and she let john have access to it
give him a smoke and that was the start
of his problem really
and then he started drinking when he was
about 11 or 12 and we didn't know you
know
as well as being dependent on alcohol
john's being prescribed
strong painkillers by his doctor when i
get back i'm going to pop all the
chocolates
forget a little pain and then i'll cry
i'll be drinking [ __ ] again
what's worrying is that john tells me he
has a history of suicide attempts
i was dead i was dead in the ambulance
we had some
electric shock treatment they start me
out me i don't know things about
knives you know what i mean why do you
drink drugs why do i drink a boat no
there's no reason for it i'm not one of
them who will tell you lord it's because
of this bad childhood and all that
nothing reason hard drink merch because
i just started drinking
what john really wants her is
painkillers which have been prescribed
by his doctor
so how many will you get 20 well 50
you'll take all 50. yo yo it wouldn't be
long
before john got his tablets
the numbers of men dying from an
alcohol-related death
are higher in the north than anywhere
else in england
to find out how destructive alcohol can
be i've come to wigan
to meet phil moore my addiction is
probably
all told lasted about 10 years um but in
the in the
last last three
um it's it's got really bad my day would
generally start with a drink
as soon as i opened my eyes the first
thing i would think about was have i got
any drink in the house
you don't wake up one morning and think
i'm going to be an alcoholic or i'm
going to be a drug addict
it creeps up and it creeps up and
before you know it your life is is
uncontrollable
there's a northern macho attitude
and to have to admit to having a problem
is
is is very difficult so the problems get
worse before they get any better so
there's potentially something about us
northern men that prevent us in some
cases from saying
i'm having a problem absolutely
a major cause of death among northern
men is suicide
with rates highest in the northeast and
the north west of england
the first thing you'd ever notice about
simon was the fact that
he had this massive smile on his face
all the time and it was just
a huge grin simon sharples took his own
life at the age of 36.
i've come to meet his brother johnny to
talk about what happened
he was just like you or me or anyone you
see in the street or anyone you'll see
at the pub or anyone you'll see at work
he was he was just a normal person
the next thing i know is i wake up on
the sunday
morning in december and to a telephone
call from my sister
and she just um tells me she's got some
bad news
and she tells me that simon's passed
away and maybe
in that moment a missing piece of the
puzzle clicks in and it just
dropped to the floor and and cried only
after it happened
when we had to we had to clear his
things away
i think we found um antidepressants i
think
if he had the opportunity to go and see
a counselor go and see a therapist or go
and talk
face to face with someone about what was
going through that might have been
better for him
but in the first instance maybe he was
prescribed the antidepressants
and that wasn't what he needed funding
for gps is crucial here
because gps are at the front line of
referring patients to mental health
services
gp practices are better funded in the
south than the north
because of the way funding is calculated
if something's
killing more men and then anything else
is killing young men
you direct the money towards that to try
and put a stop to it or try and limit it
but they just don't seem to be doing
that and they don't seem to
be putting putting the money in place
and the professionals in place and
keeping them there in the in the
nhs to help men and help women and help
help northerners southerners whoever
there's just just not enough in place
for them
back in blackpool john's spent less than
five minutes in his gp surgery and has
come out with a bag of painkillers
so what are you going to do now want to
go and swallow it all
all of it oh the job so these these
tablets are for your bad back are they
yeah
and what are they the sciatica on earth
right
and what are they got repent
strong stuff gabapentin
is used to ease nerve pain but mixing it
with alcohol
can be fatal yet no one seems to have
realized
that john is an alcohol dependent
what you've been prescribed all these in
one go yeah
and how long will how long how much of a
course is this is
the same i had the same yesterday the
same prescription
you had the same lot of tablets
yesterday where are they
but 50 in you might take 50 watt by the
end of tonight
oh yeah what 50 by the end of tonight oh
yeah
that's extraordinary then i'll possibly
walk up on that city last night
do you think people like politicians
mps doctors what politicians do you
think they
do you think they want to help you they
don't care about
us never rather they never will
they don't care about us
everyone i spoke to had a view about why
the north was different to the south
for some it's political it's a big
problem
that the south ignore really just
completely ignore it
and they can't understand why why we
voted to get out of you it's because of
that divide if
if we'd have had a fair crack of the
whip in europe
you know the money they've been
distributed evenly might have been a
different story
for others it was about money all these
reasons
or almost all of them
actually all of them are linked to
social economic deprivation
do northerners generally have a point
are the statistics borne out by that
i think northerners have a point and the
numbers
point to that you can you can argue
with these numbers the north needs
more investment it needs um
smart investment
phil found salvation in the most
unlikely of places
a detox farm surrounded by chickens and
goats
but funding made this place happen and
so during your
your rehab here this was the kind of
therapy absolutely
absolutely um i'll introduce you to the
goats soon
and uh they've they've they've been
instrumental in in my recovery
um who would have thought it eh exactly
you know um
this time 12 months ago i would never
have thought that
anything like this was possible i caught
up with john recently
he's got an appointment to see a
specialist about his back pain
and johnny now works with a charity to
help people at risk of suicide
the better we do at changing the stigma
around
being a man in the north maybe
maybe it'll work out better for us in
the long run
there's no line that separates the north
and the south
it's a concept formed from history
economics
and culture but closing the gap between
the two
is a matter of life and death